[Music]
welcome back to Tucker Carlson tonight
live from Tokyo Japan ahead of the
president's visit in our interview at
the g20 summit in Osaka back in America
a text story that might seem
insignificant but is not in fact it may
determine what happens in the next
presidential election very well may a
Google whistleblower has come forward to
describe his company's plans to remake
the American political landscape Google
of course is the most powerful company
in the world so when an anonymous
whistleblower comes forward in this case
telling project Veritas that Google is
using internal algorithms to shape what
America's see online and by extension
what they think you better take it
seriously fairness is a dog whistle it
does not mean what you think that it
means and you have to apply doublethink
in order to understand what they're
really saying and what they're really
saying about fairness is that they have
to manipulate their search results so it
gives them their political agenda that
they want and so they have to rebuy
astaire algorithms so that they can they
can get their agenda of cost that's the
definition of propaganda again being
perpetuated by the single most powerful
company in the history of the world this
is not surprising to viewers of this
show James dorm was fired for Google for
his political views is totally
conventional moderate political views
and then came on this show to describe
the culture at Google watch this there
are definitely some political biases
within Google that I was trying to shed
light on in the document and that they
affect many parts of the business and
for example who they do business with
and what type of content they create and
I really think that those political
biases need to be addressed it's not
just whistleblowers that will excuse me
hidden camera footage obtained by
Project Veritas shows a conversation
with a woman called Jen Jenai for Google
title his head of responsive innovations
responsible innovations in the global
affairs Department in that video Jen I
says that Google is working specifically
on products to make certain
Donald Trump does not win another
election quote we're also training our
algorithms like if 2016 happened again
would the outcome be different people
were not putting that line in the sand
that they were not saying that what's
fair and what's equitable so we're like
well we're a big company we're gonna say
it in other words we're gonna try and
affect the outcome of the 2020
presidential campaign tonight goes on to
blast Elizabeth Warren's proposal to
break Google up into two companies why
check out this reasoning quote all these
smaller companies who don't have the
same resources that we do will be
charged with preventing the next Trump
situation it's like a small company
cannot do that huh so using a company's
dominance on the Internet to sway the
outcome of an election that's their plan
there should be a term for what Jenai is
describing turns out there is a term
it's a term you've heard constantly from
Talking Heads on television for more
than two years
it's called hacking an election Google
wants to hack our election they're
saying that out loud as we've been told
over and over again by CNN and the
Washington Post in The New York Times
and all the other propagandists hacking
an election is very bad at minimum it
warrants a multi-year investigation by
law enforcement agencies and yet it's
happening now the Washington
establishment has said they want to
prevent election interference but of
course that's a lie they just want to
make sure they control the elections
that's their only goal that's why
they're not attacking the real source of
election interference which are Silicon
Valley Google Facebook and their ilk
that far more political power than
Russia ever has or ever will have no
serious person doubts that but the
people in charge of our country don't
care about any of that because when
Google metals in an election Democrats
benefit by the way if you want to find
that video you can't access it on
YouTube uh-huh go book took it down
that's not surprising
you can already be tossed off of YouTube
and Facebook if you decide they're using
speech you don't like they'll accuse you
of hate speech whatever that means now
they can toss you off their sites just
for putting up videos that make you look
bad they probably won't be banning in a
DNC video time any videos anytime soon
you can be
than that meanwhile this week Ravelry a
knitting social networking website with
8 million members banned all explicit
support for Donald Trump and only for
Donald Trump and they got away with it
and because they have gotten away with
that other platforms almost certainly
will do the same thing all of this is
going on fragrantly in public but most
Republicans haven't even responded to it
they haven't reacted at all as soon as
the 2016 election was over the press and
big tech openly began plotting on how to
control the narrative in 2020 which is
another way of saying control the
election outcome in 2020 and using the
scapegoat of fake news as an excuse to
control the public discourse Republicans
were in charge of Congress at the time
they did nothing the White House
commands a vast regulatory apparatus
they've sat motionless and done nothing
the only Republican who seems even
interested at all in the subject and
keeping big tech and check at all is new
senator Josh Holley he just introduced a
bill that would force tech companies to
act as genuinely open platforms in order
to receive valuable regulatory benefits
that's the deal they're violating the
deal nobody else seems to care passing
Holly's bill does not seem to be a
conservative priority though no one in
Congress is talking about it that's some
big mistake successful political parties
look out for their supporters and for
the public at large and protect them
from harm
Republicans meanwhile are sitting in a
stupefied fog of libertarianism doing
nothing while their ideas are suppressed
and their supporters are silenced one
day they'll look up and find they have
no supporters at all who will be to
blame for that only themselves